[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about peach time whatever
we want to hear so Tech is a year old
yeah oh my gosh we did it here he did it
he didn't do [ __ ] he does not exist
that's true we had to put in the time
put in the work we did all the work why
didn't we get any present
that's so I told you happy birthday
that's the reason why you did get
present Tyco is not a [ __ ] present no
give you that [ __ ]
the presents we gave him now you don't
have to buy so that's your prison I'm
not it like shopping you guys took that
away from you she does like buying Tiger
stuff come on I don't buy baby [ __ ]
unless they're old enough to remember me
so true so you didn't give tech any nope
only my love you know oh that's what the
actually I'm kidding by the way cuz it's
my first time being a parent so I was
like hey are you breaking the buy tank
up present cuz I don't want to look bad
are you Bob I am one but if you're not
then I'm not either
Oh remember [ __ ] don't it yeah you could
give up this and you'll just [ __ ] do
this all day try to put in his mouth
this is the it's this excited mentality
that leads to screaming babies at
[ __ ] Disneyland like when people were
just trying to be at Disneyland you got
to bring your [ __ ] one-year-old baby
I'm like really dude Nikki's gonna be
that mom yeah I will not be that dead
you're out of your mind well we're not
bringing oh did baby to Disneyland
listen Steve why are you out you wear
the pants in the relationship bro oh I
do what are you gonna do if you want to
bring the baby wait wait this is like
well here's the thing I think that you
guys are encountering this right where
you're so excited that you have a kid
now you want to do all the things that
you can't we couldn't wait to do with
the kid yeah so you'd end up jumping the
gun
a lot that's like you're all on the
tracks and you jump the gun every time
because you're so excited so you end up
doing a lot of stupid [ __ ] that you
don't need to do yet because you can't
wait what you can't be patient while a
kid
or fourth child always gets jack-shit
because the parents aren't excited to do
it at exactly yeah that's my theory go
oh I know I'm sure that's why I'm
looking directly at the morning saying
he had a great time just just like boom
boom like this - she took him on all the
things that he would like so we want a
small world train you guys commented a
kid it's like it's like a dog right roll
the window down and they think it's
amazing I think it's [ __ ] incredible
things are amazing in their head out of
the window that's what I'm saying so
like what's your appointment you know so
you might as well put the kid in the car
take him around the block
roll the window because he likes a lot
of lights and I don't have that many
Lego at home and patterns yet you might
burn 400 bucks to do that for one day
that's the best a point about to take
your phone and just like do that yeah
dude for 30 minutes I entertained Leia
with the water bottle we were just
playing with the water bottle for 30
minutes straight
15 minutes yeah she was trying to eat my
sunglasses and because she doesn't have
teeth yet I let her and then and then
dance like you know it's okay and I'm
like no dude it's fine because just like
absolutely they're clean before I got
there I can't wait to have a kid these
guys have this excited energy because I
will be patient in flute approach which
you might have also had a balanced
childhood for me I'm happy to do these
things for him cuz I'm just doing the
things I don't about to do so you're
living through tyka I can see the
excitement through his eyes and it makes
me feel good because I never got a
chance to go of Disney I was like 15 no
I get it but he doesn't even know he
doesn't know he's mad but he does get
stimulated and I see his eyes get really
big and that makes me happy but how
greats are gonna be when he's at
Disneyland and he knows he's a decent
man that's gonna be even better yeah
yeah they'll be evil rub it in their
face and [ __ ] oh man you remember me
I don't even know what this is a
connective absolutely love it's like you
remember me it's like what I'm gone you
remember me know if I give them a gift
or take them anywhere yeah that's why
it's like it's like the other day when I
went out when we're at the party I was
asking Isaac do you remember Hawaii and
he's like yeah and I was like do you
remember us swimming and he was like
yeah I'm like you better you better
remember you know it sucks he remembers
everything with everyone but for some
reason his brain blocks me from his
memories like just recently we got him
new glasses cuz the other ones he broke
and I took him to go get his glasses
fitted and everything and so I was there
when he picked him out but since I hurt
my ankle I couldn't go with him to pick
them up after they were ready so he gets
home I'm like hey I haven't seen you
with your glasses he shows me as best as
I'm like cool did they adjust him for
you and something he was like no but
when I went to go pick them out they
were doing this and then I was like I
was there I think he went alone though
in his memory he drove there he was like
oh yeah and I'm like you know what that
means no that means you're doing a great
job as a mom because you're not absent
enough if you were more absent he would
be so thirsty for you you also mean that
he's legitimately your son yep because
there's almost nothing that I hear you
say more than oh yeah you don't say one
more time when I bring something I feel
like oh that's right genetically like
you know something you don't take it
personal it's just a clone of you yeah I
know but it's just I get sad cuz then
we'll talk about certain memories and
you only remembers like kinky being
there are you guys being there other
people and I'm like do you remember what
we did and like the only things like he
remembers like the only thing that his
memory has is when I yell at
or like when we're angry at like it's
just a boy I'm like god dammit like all
his memories are gonna be of me just
whenever a medic it's cuz you're
confident yeah it's because you're is
his constant yeah yeah like when we went
to Japan I was telling him about Japan
and I was just like do you remember you
yelled at me and then he was like I
remember you got mad they're like is
that Disneyland member he was so bad
that time he was he was such a brat no
one ever was like is it I think yeah he
was really bad what was that terrible
force 7:07 oh [ __ ] isn't it like
terrible every year yeah after -
honestly yeah so he was like eight like
eight nine that's him he's been like a
wonderful so from two to nine is
troublesome yeah great yeah is there
like a like you know how like there's
dog trainers for obedience school for
dogs is there some [ __ ] like that first
yeah that's called good parents none
like all Mary Poppins dude yeah Mary
Poppins nannies remember that show the
the nanny show maybe not one one good
sounds good right there's professional
nannies yeah and the other day and they
were all British they better be ready
for the fire I mean all yellow your kid
the whole time have a fake British
actually just it's not like this guy go
for go tell me about my child your child
is very beautiful
yeah they sound like they don't say that
[ __ ] Gordon Ramsay boy yelling they they
know they're like like your child is out
of control control control I'm telling
you that's the [ __ ] yeah and then they
have those dresses were like their butt
is really big and in it like a Victorian
[ __ ] booty they pour like an English
tea for the kid and they throw the
[ __ ] face I love those shows man I
love that corrective children's school
no
you'll never need those hopefully I
could be involved in my kids [ __ ]
life it's a lot of work man like I
honestly like the easiest part is just
punch you know like those like first
what eight years my the easiest part was
just changing their diapers and like
feeding them late at night like I would
do that over and over and over and over
and over again like be a decent human
it's so hard as you're saying this my
kid in the futures hanging on his
friends and he's like starting his hands
are going invisible wait that's like
back to the future yeah exactly
hopefully hopefully my kids not driving
the car while I'm sitting there and I
see him starting to fade it's because
you were a single mom so the the
responsibilities and all the [ __ ] that
you had to do the rave the raising and
all that yeah honestly yeah because do
you feel like the teamwork now is a lot
better for sure like having Casey in his
life so Casey came into his life when
Isaac was a he was four about the ten
five so since then things have gone a
lot easier but then even in that like
the first few years Casey was really
hands-off because if he was trying to
figure out his his place in his he's
like I can't tell you what to do I'm not
your daddy yeah and then like he was
just very like well you know like just
really respectful of the boundaries and
stuff so it was still like mainly just
me just Casey bodystyle him now does
Casey walk around in his underwear and
drink a beer he's [ __ ] wife beater
we'll talk to you much and tell
everybody to shut up Casey put it poor
babe just Casey pour beer do McDonald's
Cup Drive Isaac to school and say the
whole time if he does then he's that
boy's father
it's just passive into
now he's such a good little secret
that's my that's what I said
I feel like caring too much or trying to
control it too much is gonna be it's
what's gonna cause me to be more
stressed out so I just gotta be careless
and let the [ __ ] go the other way that's
good there's no equilibrium like the
extremes right before abandonment
you know like almost yeah damn not like
kind of borderline neglected you just
don't want them to cry when you die
that's a true saying yeah yeah don't cry
for me you know ii mean like it's it's
cool you know Lila bring I'll save you
the tears but just enough to were like
okay I'm you know maybe feeding them
that's important you're the guy that
pays the bill very important I Abed
maybe one one blanket gonna me not maybe
- ahh - you don't want him to be a [ __ ]
mm-hmm
if it's in the warm part of the house he
does even need a blanket yeah we got the
heater on it's a girl she can have two
blankets because they're always buzzing
hope they're always yeah different body
temperatures yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know at least two meals at least maybe
one or two you know what you said at
least two and then you went back to one
another one or three three meals is a
mean dude yeah it's a mean so what you
see the one big meal or there are three
small ones
well they need like eight meals under
really though what do you want cuz
you're just [ __ ] around right now
what do you mean what kind of dad are
you gonna be
don't be fun but I don't think I don't
know like I think I got a lot of anger
problems where like when I'm normal I'm
fine but when I'm mad I'm a different
person so I gotta get that [ __ ]
corrected before I pop out any kids
because they'll be all cute and [ __ ] and
as soon as they piss me off I'm punching
that [ __ ] in the stomach even
though I don't believe in corporal
punishment there's one thing to believe
in it and there's another thing to like
control yourself and I'm on that
spectrum I cannot control myself just
yet
so one day I might [ __ ] like think
he's a football and kick him in the butt
and he flies and I go to jail you know
so or maybe having a kid will change you
maybe make you
I think so all the dice that maybe wants
it because I don't I don't beat my dog
so maybe but the gun that's true so the
dogs are so adorable even if they're
[ __ ] up but like I feel like a human
being will just cut you way more than an
animal you think you've changed at all
we're having thangka changed in terms of
like the anger and that part of it um I
mean I didn't beat I haven't beat like
the last couple of my dogs
I did I did I did the first couple so I
think I had good practice yeah that's
good but definitely like since day one
Tiger challenges you like the first day
you bring him home and he's crying all
over and over and like just just just a
baby yeah yeah there's just a level of
frustration that you've never felt
before where like you try to put him
asleep it's 2:00 a.m. in the morning the
wakes up again you put them back to
sleep oh she's not got to change the
diaper you're just constant and then
it's it's like staying up for like 14
days straight you know I didn't it's and
then so almost and then you have work
stress and then all the other stuff so
what's like one little thing which is
just feeding him turns into like this
huge huge thing and there's never cross
my mind to punch him in the face
that's because he's a baby still wait
till he's like at the beating age ya
know so right now isn't he just
qualified for the beating itch but I
still haven't had there like one urge to
like well I mean the stories that I
heard when I was like six months my my
when I was crying my dad would take me
and throw me in the bathroom to lock the
door six months yes sounds pretty normal
my mom had to kick the door down so I
thought six months was the beating age
are you not worse than what that's not a
beating noise isolation okay so I guess
I didn't know
I didn't try to isolate them sorry I
didn't that's good you talk about
punishment age yeah I didn't try to
isolate them anything yeah yeah no so
wait design with all this you guys do
you wanna have another one give like a
sibling do you mean well you're just
talking like math so much [ __ ] work
absolutely work that's why I'm saying
realistic you like from 2 to 8 it's not
gonna work and then you I was talking to
you 2 days ago you're like yeah but do
you have another kid now I know what to
expect this is why I think it's a
biological thing dude should I control
it you know well who was it that told us
that as soon as you give birth you
forget about all the pain because then
biologically it's your wired to want to
have another kid I did but it was just
because that's what women say but I
don't think it's like a scientific thing
hmm
and honestly I wouldn't I wouldn't want
to have another kid except that I grew
up as an only child I know it's up for
Tiger so we're doing it for hands we can
have a companion
I gotcha but like with how busy we are
in like she works I work like no another
kid because of time yeah mainly because
of time but if you had time would you
have a pack of wolves he doesn't know
I'm saying that you're yes we had time
but I also think in our day and age it's
unrealistic with the amount of goal or
just people that you and me we like to
do everything yeah so it'd be like
giving all that up and I don't think
it's realistic would you have like eight
kids yeah would you have if it was like
the 1800s I would I want a lot of kids
if I had a lot of family members to take
care of them for me true what a lot of
kids are out of the take this one so I
am for robots cuz you guys you're
talking about having many kids I'm like
well we're not if you had a robot friend
oh you know I started reading articles
about robot nannies
like there's people that are having
robots take care of their kids and then
you're gonna have robot nannies with
friend mode so now you don't need to
have two kids you can all have a single
kid and they can add like robot nanny
turns into fred mode real quick and then
like they're throwing ball around and
[ __ ] why is that sad we're not zero this
is turning real we're gonna lock door to
dark room yeah that would if you had a
robot friend instead
SiC there are other trained monkeys and
dogs I rather yeah I'd rather have an
animal friend yep something has real I
want a chimpanzee what have you
connected with your robot friend and
your robot friend became your best
friend right now if I were to kill them
but then one day the government decides
that your robot friend is a threat to
humanity potentially oh they destroy
your robot friend with a nuclear device
No before the nuclear device goes on
your robot friend saves you your you and
your your country some confuse do you
want kids or not I would like to have
kids yes that sounds like et but the
robot kind I just want a robot is what
I'm getting I want a robot too I don't
know what kind I just know I want two
army of them get a dog robot that's the
best cuz they never die and then they're
inferior to you still that's pretty good
I don't want a robot not to replace
companionship I just want a robot to
just do mechanical things but I don't
ever want to have a relationship with
the robot why like you know like at the
Roomba are you robot racist yes
so you know like the Roomba at home like
I don't go oh good job four-vector I do
a good job you don't want to have a real
relationship with like this mechanical
music I probably have a relationship
with this [ __ ] pear peach whatever
this is I want to have real
relationships with real things like what
about your car animals yeah what about
your car not Kalu's I could buy my dream
car and someone crashed into the next
day I'm cool with it I'm like it's it's
material but you're also talking to
someone that has very slim chance of
just having new friends though like
Steve the fact that your new friend
you're mine how his friend you know
that's pretty cool yeah that's why wild
I don't connect with very many people
are you it cuz you don't go out but even
if I did out the world I get it man I
get it I mean you want to have to want
to go out you spent your childhood in a
locked bathroom I get it now is my
playground
yeah I don't have very many real friends
put you in the bathroom too yeah when I
was really little my mom she had to go
to work my dad was nowhere to be found
and she locked me in the bathroom
what a fun story Wow boy you gotta find
one killer beat you
Jesus I think you have pretty decent
pants yeah a decent parents not average
even if they did they didn't tell me
yeah right that's my that's my thing
well the only reason why phonos cuz when
I got older my mom said that somehow I
got out one of the days and then I
walked over to her job because she
worked down the street like neighbors
found me and then took me to my mom's
job and they're like I just find your
daughter walking in the street is crazy
and she got mad because you embarrassed
her well I mean like we turned out great
- considering uh that type of upbringing
huh
you guys are in prison yes babies I know
that's why I want to go back to prison
why I didn't get beat like crazy maybe
that's why you're tougher than me I feel
like girls don't get beat that hard also
because they don't do stupid [ __ ]
yeah we're Lots yeah they're not a super
[ __ ] I shaved my eyebrows off but that's
not as dumb as me upset a building on
fire hide my parents keys just to watch
them panic I know right
so they would be like [ __ ] yeah I'm all
like no cuz my stupid I'm actually sad
cuz that means you didn't want them to
leave you yeah but yeah this is how they
knew it was me cuz I would be like huh
where is it oh I think I know
and then like I would take up to the
couch and I'll be like I think I can't
saw it here and they're like what the
[ __ ] and because they're like obviously
you put it there cuz you knew exactly
where it was and your shitty acting
skills come on as be but I will keep
doing it though you don't mean what if
you're just gonna binding it and then it
teaches you never to help them find
that's what I do
I think it was my poor acting skills
that like and sometimes I would put it
like in an area that would never be
there like under the the counter man if
that did that [ __ ] I wouldn't be pissed
that I might be like [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
shitty parent that always like kittens
are you gonna have kids while you're
panicking and you're already 30 minutes
late and your kids laughing at you
I would solid yet you decided you're
having kids just like that yeah with
kids I don't know a lot of them what you
can't pick a tune oh I know you can I
mean they cost a lot of money but I'm
scared to punish her that's really
that's what the moms for bro and then
you're gonna push the [ __ ] out of your
son though vampire shameless when you
say you're scared too Punisher what does
that mean like you're afraid is that
gonna make her crime to feel so bad oh I
see why I don't know it's like you don't
want to make the girl Kim right now I
don't feel as bad you're punished Kim oh
yeah yeah I sure in many ways you know
what I mean yeah I think just seeing my
daughter crying I just feel like you'll
get over it
I don't get that a vagina or death or
crime actual not until your sexist
because that's exactly that's exactly
right yeah yeah beat them equal if I do
beat them equally
unlike sexist ass [ __ ] over here
choo choo and I should also like
high-five my daughter when she gets laid
hell yeah that's weird that's that's
being sexist the right is that sexist
I'm high-fiving both of them there's
that sexism I would not high-five the
girl I'm a sexist you know why it's
because I I if it looks like Nikki I'm
just gonna be pissed the whole time yeah
I think that's what happens to dad's
right well what if she looks like you
though I hope to god she
how about that holy [ __ ] not sheep he
looks like her that I mean him that's
fine I hope my son and daughter look
like Nikki how about that Amanda yeah we
all do right but but as far as I don't
know man think a little Nikki or like um
teenage Nikki or even like a 20 year old
Nikki she's gonna look like Nikki and
that's just gonna piss me the [ __ ] off
no matter what you're getting plowed by
many men right I'm just gonna yeah I
know
yes exactly how that's a father what can
do you all you can do is kill the guys
right all you can do is watch like your
wife when you first met her get plowed
by other men and you're just like that's
what I think is that that's why I think
there's this dad vent because I think
it's like that right cuz you see her in
I don't think anyone sees it like that I
think they just see their precious
little child now getting plowed yeah but
a few precious little son and he's
getting his dick sucked no handshake I
would care a lot that's what makes sense
cuz it's the wife that she's the husband
getting but he looks like me that's true
I'm so gonna be [ __ ] that's not baby
you stupid hooker I don't care if they'd
they both get laid and good for both of
them that's the mom is not okay with
both but the dads okay fit the son like
you're not gonna care when Isaac has sex
right well I mean it's that's why I like
whenever we would talk about it like
Isaac was growing up oh my gosh I know
but like I don't want to think about I
get it I just don't want to think about
it and it's like he can do his his own
life and like I'll try not to be one of
those like obsessive mother-in-law's I
just treat their daughter-in-laws like
[ __ ] I'll try my heart is never to be
like that but it's also really hard to
think about like you know he's a
[ __ ] Kendall yeah what that's how I
wouldn't think of it man yeah but when
he brings home a girl right and
he's hanging with her alive and it's not
really hanging out with mom anymore then
you know he starts to move in with her
and he's living with her and there's
just something I have to deal with I
can't bottle him forever can start
traveling now that's awesome June come
true alright but you know I'm not gonna
hear from him as much cuz how he's you
know off with this other girl who's
almost like his new mom and way break
down
[Music]
[Music]